no now Chad is a he's a very different
profession Jojo Jordan I know you guys
are so happy together now you are one of
Bachelor nation's incredible success
stories but what was it like to relive
Jojo ceaseth it was great for me I mean
she was I was loving exactly watches the
first time around
you got watched like the first episode
maybe a little bit in a second I was
like I'm good I don't need to see it now
I'm like four years in let's watch all
of it let's watch you're making out all
over the place and now he's just like
making fun of me 24/7 so that's good Wow
so Jordan you didn't watch really any of
it because that's usually something that
bachelor couples point as kind of a
problem once they get off the show is
they have to be together in secret and
then rewatching the season and seeing
everything that happened can be kind of
painful so you just didn't watch it yeah
I didn't I didn't even see this analogy
obviously because I think that's the
final rose when it's live with it I
didn't see any of that so see the
proposal again and everything I mean it
was unreal I think we're necessarily
walk not watch it because I was worried
about watching that you've got enough
problems those first couple months are
crazy and a nightmare and so hard and so
we were going through a lot in a moment
so I need if we get enough to do it I'm
gonna wake up every morning and choose
you over and over and over again until
you tell me I can turn in I
love you so much I've been waiting to
tell you that I love you you got to
watch that proposal moment back when I
was rewatching and I wrote down great
speeches Jojo and Jordan click when you
guys look back at what you said to each
other what is it like to watch those
words and did you remember much of it
are we kind of blacked out this is so
funny
because in my mind I thought it was like
this perfect like I was super excited
and happy
you watched it back joins like geese
your face do you see it like you had
this like hesitant like moment and I
thought it was over modeling which is
terrible I say I'm like excited I'm
nervous he's like you thought she was
about to dump you yeah I know she just
went through a tough you know breakup
and it's 120 degrees on the haze and I'm
like it's over I guess I'll do my speech
anyway I didn't realize how nervous I
was like I was so nervous that I could
see it in my face I can see it in every
part of me and so when I watch oh my
gosh I was so nervous even though like I
had the power which you don't have the
power this is the two-way street here I
was so nervous - so that was funny what
was making you so nervous did part of
you think Jordan might not propose I
don't know I just think it's a really
big moment and I think my emotions were
just I think at that point you know
leading up to that moment you never
really know we had conversations he was
ready but you also really never know so
maybe that was a small factor but I
think more than anything I just was like
my emotions were so crazy I am finding
why I didn't I don't know yeah I was
nervous so when you guys were watching
it back was there anything else that you
had forgotten that you were reminded of
or maybe you remember differently well
an amnesia
no you remember a lot of details when I
I really struggle with remembering so
many things and I think when people
asked me like what advice would you give
to future bachelor/bachelorette and was
like if it's the most amazing time of
your life you'll never be able to go
back to that journal write things down
write moments down that really stood out
to you because when I go back and I try
to think about it just forgot about love
story your emotions are so crazy like
what's fun to watch back like we both
got emotional like it was really really
fun to see them really sweet I got
emotional you know and later it was four
years ago and which seems just like
forever but at the same time not that
long it was a really special thing well
I think it's also that a lot has
happened for you guys in four years what
moments made you emotional and did you
get to tears I love it you already
forgot you know what I'm talking to
producers I wasn't sure what they were
gonna show they were not going to show
it I remember them I mean there was this
moment like Jordan was speaking about
like at the end of his you know when he
thought about his future and his wife he
always envisioned somebody but there was
never face to that person and now he saw
me at the end of that I feel like I just
saw goosebumps again every time it says
that it just like on an all get
emotional and and on top of like having
to postpone our wedding and so I think I
just got emotional talking if you got it
well I love hearing this because I will
tell you when I spoke to Caitlin into
Ben not Sean and Catherine but when I
talked to Kaitlyn and Ben they were both
a lot more gun-shy about watching their
season I was like that when I first
heard I was sick to my stomach
no like it's great part of our story you
know we love Ben so
Jojo is it so do you think it was harder
for you to watch your own the season
back or to watch you on Ben Higgins his
season back still watch me on Ben our
cable wasn't working that night save
myself from that trauma
oh so weird my dad was like you don't
need to see that it made me so sad my
dad he was like yeah you always forget
like the heartbreak that you know your
child goes through in that moment so
when he watched fencing the bag he was
like I was so sad as I saw you so sad
they cannot broke my heart
I remember watching the hotel when we
were on lockdown I was like yeah because
I figured oh you have you were on a
different type of lockdown
yes well he was waiting to announce the
Bachelorette and because I was a last
minute you know everyone so it was a
very last me he kept saying that there
was a maybe I'll just slide into DN and
I won't go on to this event like it's an
experience that was a I remember that
being like a little bit of a rumor with
you guys maybe it wasn't DMS but wasn't
it that you had talked before the season
yeah okay which is I'm not sure
whatsoever the only knowledge I had up
Jordan was I knew he was gonna be on my
season because that had been leaked and
yeah I saw this photo so I looked at his
Instagram like I think like a week
before my feet I get it
put this any guy that I knew was gonna
be on my season I was trying to get like
the info before my phone got taken away
so that was the only thing I knew again
very alright we've set the record
straight here today um
yeah do the Recon work like I know
Claire Crawley's doing that right now
how could you not have to ask you what
were you thinking about Jordan going in
just kind of knowing that surface level
stuff about him you know I really
attract just all the things in my head
he gave me no reason to think that but I
just started going that's the self
sabotage all season I was like really
like this guy's falling in love with him
hoodies he like this what do you do like
that but what if this and what if that
wasn't put that crap out maybe the trust
her got trust her heart push your
instinct and with him I always say like
at that time I thought it was me taking
a risk
little did I know is the safest decision
I've ever made in my life I went back
and looked at the transcription of when
I interviewed you at your photo shoot to
be the Bachelorette and I asked you you
know about the Caleb rumors and you said
look I wasn't gonna believe it until I
heard it from Chris Harrison's mouth
that I was the Bachelorette 100% and I
think all of us being considered thought
well there's a good chance it can be me
but there's also not and so yeah you
just never you never jumped the gun you
waited out any weight so prisoner and
says it and then you're good I think it
was like oh maybe a week before because
I remember once I found out it was like
a race to get all my fittings done and
he was carry and it was like a really
fast process so Jordan what if it had
been gala to me honestly it didn't
really matter like I I was late to the
party like I wasn't in the recruiting
process I got called like ten days
before the show start filming and was
like hey ever watch and I'm like nope
he's like are you sick no I'm like yep
he's like alright well here's what the
shows about
I didn't know who Caylor was no Jojo was
I've been watching the season so I kind
of made that decision I'm like look I'm
open to finding love
who's gonna happen on a TV show and
probably not but like it could be an
experience so I kept saying that when I
finally realized it wasn't yeah I hope
it's Jojo I definitely I watched like
the final two episodes Wow
and just like you know what I made this
decision before I knew who was so I'm
just gonna do it regardless Joelle Hanna
pleasure
[Music]
give me that hand
how did they find you it's it's a weird
story like I was in sports media so I'm
doing football college football stopping
like someone had reached out a fox TV so
it reached out to my agency and they
wanted an ex-football player and then
they never call back and someone there
knew someone at the bachelors my name
got passed over and there you go
Wow so when you're watching those final
episodes of Ben's season are you
thinking this guy is letting this woman
go yes which by the way that's kind of a
thing in bachelor nation the past couple
years like I'm paradise especially a
couple years ago was the in each other's
DMS beforehand it sounds like you guys
do not advise that I'm gonna die I gotta
bring up Ben for a minute because they
are airing your seasons back-to-back
weeks and of course Ben infamously said
I love you to two women that he told me
that one of his regrets he said was
saying I love you to you and I'd
actually never heard him say that before
that it was a regret of his um I think
he of course meant it just because he
feel felt like he ended up causing hurt
and making things messy what do you
think should he have said that to you do
you wish he had not Oh
I mean looking back of course I don't I
think that the heartbreak was even
harder and worse knowing that this
person had said the Bennets that I love
you and I couldn't live my life that
were you you're my best Frank's I think
it just you have this expectation and
hearing those things makes you think how
could it be anyone else so I think it
definitely made it harder I don't fault
him I'm not mad that he said he was very
honest and his feelings in that moment
wouldn't it made easier probably a
little bit for me and probably for him
forlorn things probably have been very
different with how things were handled
afterwards but then we do the best
in these situations and I even told
Venice you know right after that
happened I was like listen after going
through it myself like I have so much
more respect for you yeah because at the
time I couldn't understand how you could
do that but I get it it's a no one will
ever understand it you don't know how to
prepare for it and you do the best you
can and you've got to give yourself a
little bit of grace yeah I mean I'm I
don't yeah if you've read it I mean
whatever you know what I mean we all do
the best we can
it would have made it easier though if I
didn't think Jordan thank you for being
so producer minded even at the expense
of Jodi's actions
Ben actually also told me you know him
and Lauren there were rumors about them
struggling especially because he'd said
those two I love yous and then they
broke up and Ben said that looking back
he thinks throughout their first year
him and Lauren were probably kind of
looking for an out and you guys had
mentioned tough times right after the
show
was there ever a moment especially
during that first year when you two
thought we might not make it you can you
can simplify this we met on a TV show
like it was just by chance like it was a
fairy tale and it's not real life I mean
there's a million excuses you can bring
about and there was a moment and like
what you're in crazy ups and downs bad
fights arguments and then we just kind
of sat down we were like just broken and
we're like we love each other but that
doesn't mean that this is gonna work out
it was kind of one of two ways we could
go and we decided to write their foot
down and be better and it was not easy
yeah it's still growth from that moment
on but it's tough it's a tough little be
thrown into because you're getting to
know somebody wow you're in the know
absolutely I mean any any couple that
comes out of this that first year it's
it's the hardest and it's the easiest I
think to walk the way from
I get it it was so tough and you know
it's I'm so glad like we got there like
think about it there were so many
moments where we could have parted way
and you wouldn't be here now
we've such a beautiful life and family
together
is there news but it's just it's amazing
like if you work together and you work
on those new thing if you love each
other
one one decision can change the whole
course of your life and so it's just
crazy to think about well just cuz that
is such a good a relationship lesson for
people I guess I would ask you guys what
were the things causing those major ups
and downs and what did you do to move
past that time when you decided to I
think in the beginning the biggest thing
for me was there were so many rumors
going on after the show about Jordan
obviously I was never used to the media
and tabloid and like I didn't understand
that world at all and so that was a lot
of pressure on me and then you start
doubting like do I really know this
person what's true what's not true and
then that causes friction between your
relationship because you're supposed to
be each other is like rockin and support
until that rolled into really bad
communication between the two of us we
didn't know how to communicate with each
other we have very different styles and
so it was just like one thing on top of
the other about the other and I mean at
that point we could we could fight about
anything that first year I mean anything
I was just with so much I'm sure he had
sort of resentment you don't ever get to
have conflict on show you really don't
you may have a little bit and but you
never you never learn how to fight well
anyway that's in a relationship knows
that you need to know how to navigate
relationships in conflict what your
partner needs and how they need to
communicate you did not know how to do
that and we're on different worlds of
how we end
that interesting work and so we had to
learn how to do that it's something that
we said there was that one moment that I
think was a really big breakthrough
where we were both broken and upset and
just we just looked at each other we're
making this promise to each other we
love each other I want it to work we
have to both work towards that I think
it was just that conscious decision
every time that we got into an argument
taking a step back and yes we love each
other but we also need to respect each
other yeah and so just really focusing
on that day there are moments we'll be
discussing or arguing about some like
okay this is going to take a moment it
could be that so it's just it's always
gonna be work and I think that that's
what makes relationships last though
well what was it that made you guys hold
on just that love that gut instinct yeah
I think it was I think you look back to
all the good moments in you could chalk
it up to a TV show if you want but I
think we both realized that there was
something extremely real and that at the
core of it we were best friends
and we were the best things for each
other there spike all the outside noise
and the arguments the ups and downs that
come along with the new relationship
especially one like this so we just was
coming back now understanding that is
that we make each other better we're
best friends and if you have that then
we can get through whatever this crap is
well Jojo I went back again and looked
at the photoshoot interview you say you
know what you want what qualities are
you looking for oh gosh I mean I have a
whole list of things that I would want
but honestly I don't I just want someone
who is genuine and makes me laugh and is
my best friend
it's as simple as that but it's very
hard to find you know I know I always
think well you hear people say a lot I
just want somebody who I can like have a
conversation with which sounds so simple
but it's such a big it's like no you
really are looking for that person who
you can always talk to I think you
always had I mean and I want to hear
from you but you always seem to have
this gut feeling about Jordan um I also
interviewed you on your firefighter date
and asked you who your three
frontrunners were and you said Jordan
named him first and I need to say Luke
and Robbie so I guess you you seem like
somebody who operates off of gut
instinct a lot of really handsome guys
on my season right and there was a lot
of good-looking men obviously I was
attracted to Jordan but the thing that
stood out to me the Moses I was very
comfortable with it and I was very
nervous that first night with everything
everything about that first night first
meat week month I was nervous
there was a sense of peace when I spoke
to him even though I had like the
butterflies and stuff there was this
weird sense of just like comfort and I
thought that that was just yeah rare and
it really and we saw you guys have your
first kiss what was it like to watch
that back that was funny because I
wanted to do it the first time around in
like god I don't know I was just like
overwhelmed by the whole TV thing and
cameras and people around and then I got
offer a little mini date that first
night me and I should've kissed her and
I'm like one of the producers like you
can do it okay that kiss was amazing
I'm hoping to get a few more of those
glad you out with it so I look so young
and I look so nervous every time I talk
about anything I just went with it I
remember that day you were like even I
asked you your frontrunners work and I
remember you stopped and you turn to the
producer and you're like can I answer
that you just don't know of course as he
was called bad Chad Jordan you and bad
Chad things came to a head with you too
Jojo looking back how did Chad stay
around as long as he did listen everyone
knew that Chad was the drama of the
season I think producers knew that I
think that obviously do you have a
villain you know that they're gonna last
a little bit longer they should however
I will say that I really did give Chad
to benefit the doubt you know he was
going through some family stuff before
he came in he had a story and I just
there was a part of me that was like
he's dealing with something and like I
don't understand me I'll never be able
to understand what he's going through
but I have this I had a soft spot for
her because I felt like I felt like I
was getting to know the real Chad I
didn't know the second I get to see what
we do I didn't get to see that you know
so I just I wanted to give him the
benefit the doubt and I just knew what
he was going through and so felt for a
while you know I just kept trying and
trying it and once I started to hear all
the things I was like with him at some
point it's enough and that was goodbye
but you always need people the better
for the gap you know he's right - I had
no clue but I will say when I found out
and you gonna producer bought the second
week if you remember when Alex told you
there was drama in the house and it was
with Jordan and then the switch I love
it you went into mama bear mode you like
not my man
my number-one frontrunner we see that on
camera you confront Jen's check out and
say you were coming in Jordan it looks
like you went a little blind for a
moment there like very that that was a
turning point you know now chad is a
he's a very different profession I will
say I did not see that coming okay you
really did have such a great season of
guys Jojo I mean you watch it back and
you're like there's Derek and Evan is
that kind of part of the joy of watching
it is that it sees these people who many
of whom by the way have found other near
relationships that are happier oh I love
them all so happy now Carly everyone is
kind of found their passion they're
happy and I just I got lucky
yeah we're really lucky these guys are
awesome I had I mean I had such a fun
time you know I mean they all became my
friends at the end of the day so I love
that about the whole experience I forgot
how much Wells couldn't you and you were
so supportive he kissed you and you said
that was the moment get a lot of air
time on the look back I forgot about
Vinnie he was great
yes what do you think you'll tell is
kind of your favorite moment from your
love story on your season favorite
moment I think you know I love looking
back there was something special about
our first one-on-one date your wife not
to mention it we were on a red-eye two
hours sleep I've cooked in Mendoza I
feel like was a big turning point for me
as well like stomping grapes take a ride
a plane there so we got a lot of like
time that was on camera
which is valuable like to talk and feel
like it's real noticing the breakthrough
moment you know is there I think there
were nerves on his anion I'm sure people
with a little bit of a wall because he
don't know what to expect but and watch
back maybe see different moments there's
these breakthrough moments where I see
him those walls just totally come down
and it gets really full like now I'm
getting into like really Jordan and what
he's feeling so those there was a couple
moments and Nemacolin moments where
their baby faked breakthrough moments
that just really one of the best moments
learn that didn't make camera was in the
hometowns I was trying to copy Oh to
these notes which is off-limits no I
don't like communicate off-camera
so somehow I tried to pass through the
notes and someone found out and so then
and when the producers got the notes and
he's like hey give it to the giver these
on camera and I'm like look I see her
later off-camera and so after our
interviews at their hometown we didn't
give you a loan in time but there was
like us in sweats in and out which like
producers and no cameras yeah sit on the
hotel room flooring in and out now it's
like pretty cool crushing some hand
where's I
I literally wrote down as I was watching
it back one of my notes was their
relationship seems real and I mean that
to just say like when you're Jojo when
you're talking about you know kind of
wanting to make sure your heart's not
gonna get broken
cuz been told you these things and it's
Jordan
real I felt like I was watching a real
kind of challenging conversation on a
date and when you guys had that first
kiss and I think you pull back and you
say I feel really comfortable with you
you see the real connection I mean how
real even though you were filming a TV
show and and you were about to start it
all but that first night that first kiss
how real did things feel to you so real
which is crazy because I'm there with
you know 30 guys and however many I
can't remember but it's like in that
moment I forgot that anyone else is
involved or that I was even on one of
the benches already no you forget those
things I forgot that in that moment so
that was like huge to me I was like whoa
like even so just just gentle normal
kids like crazy but um you know it's 91
and I do want to ask of course about
your wedding and your engagement
Jordan you to end up reap raposa the
different ring why was that important
for you to do and did you think was it
kind of interesting to watch the
original proposal now knowing that you
did it again
yes oh gosh the second proposal with us
everything that every guy goes through
nothing set up it's not scripted it's
not beautiful and perfect I was wanted
to though I think not to take away from
our first proposal but I always wanted
it to bring something that kept more
time to think about or I knew were
better to know exactly what you wanted
and I wanted to do something that was
just us so there was no cameras there
was no professional photographer we were
under the guise of taurine a venue for a
wedding which I knew what that was gonna
be the venue I think make sure that that
wasn't and I told the lady that was
showing us is like hey if you see
anything just pull your phone and just
get a Swedish one shaky little video
Jojo had no idea what was happening
there was enough like I look terrible
I'm like it doesn't matter like I just
wanted something that was just us and
something that we could call just our
- even though the first one was as
realist as anything and so special
no glam team on that one Jojo D how much
time did you spend picking out the first
ring versus the second ring the first
thing is really easy like five or six
options right away I'm like that one the
corners they're like well you know make
it look like you're no harder to decide
and then the second one I mean I pretty
much knew her so well at that point I
knew exactly what she wanted and
actually we had talked about leave me
should reset your old ring and so I was
kind of picking her brain under that
[Music]
and so you guys were supposed to get
married you posted about it that date
has come and gone I know look I know
that you guys are down to earth enough
people to have the perspective of like
okay there are worse things but it's
still it's your wedding and you put all
this time into it and you've been
together for years just emotionally what
was it like to kind of see that day come
and go there was a few moments right
when we were considering the option of
maybe do we have to postpone that I was
bummed out I knew that like pushing it
to fall wasn't going to be an option so
I knew if it wasn't gonna happen in June
it was gonna have to be next year
because football season he works 24/7 so
the realization of oh it's not just
gonna be a few months foot she's gonna
be an entire year that kind of bummed me
off but at the end of the day I mean we
want that day to be exactly what we want
we want our guests and our family our
principal thanks uncomfortable and it
just did not feel right whatsoever to
sort of roll the dice on that um and
look we had everything planned so now
it's stress free leading up to it like I
work good I was gonna say is it and I
don't know it I mean many people have
had to reschedule but are you guys just
doing everything you were gonna do in a
year you're not changing anything okay I
mean
I don't drop a stir I don't trust her
old dress teacher as soon as she made
the decision the final allegedly
decisions she's still on you know you
know this is but you have a whole year
the Wolfie well by the way I mean I
don't know if you it's also like what
are you gonna do for the next year have
you guys talked about what does this
next year now that you do have this kind
of extra time look like I know you've
moved into your house and then you love
your dogs like what is the next year
look like for you to I can just work as
usual you know Jordan's going back to
football you think that's getting ready
to start back up we're always looking
for new remodel or renovation or new
build project so we're really going to
continue to work on that and just I
think why was normal you never really
know what we're getting into it yeah
we're all over the place but worki stay
healthy in Mexico we had a family member
during the quarantine we got a new puppy
and like school since we gotta wait a
year for the wedding and we're all 24/7
we added to the family so we got another
little puppy about a month ago yeah just
do you just go for it and and try to
have kids and then the wedding dress is
beautiful Maternity with a couple months
to get back and shavings perfect jokes
about this first dog yeah it'll be worse
buddy first yeah
[Music]